the cozy car company ships some of their
new cars to japan and vietnam
the number of cars that will be shipped
to japan during the next two months is
modeled by the function j of t is equal
to two to the t power the number of cars
that will be shipped to vietnam during
the next 10 months is modeled by the
function
v of t is equal to 2 t squared which
country will
which country had received more cars
from the cozy car company after five
months or will have received after five
months so let's see how much japan is
going to receive after five months so t
is in months so j
of 5
is going to be equal to two to the fifth
power which is equal to two times two
times two times two times two and let's
see two times just four eight sixteen
thirty two
so japan will have received 32 cars and
vietnam so v of 5 is going to be 2
times 5
squared which is going to be 2 times 25
which is equal to 50.
so based on these two models for how
much they're going to
receive after t months after five months
vietnam is going to receive vietnam is
going to receive more cars
so i guess the answer to that is vietnam
viet
nam will have received more cars after
five months
which country had received more cars
from the cozy car company or will have
received more cars after seven months
so
once again let's try this out
j of 7 is equal to 2 to the 7th power
let's see 2 to the 6 is going to be 32
times this is we can do this as 2 to the
5th
times two times two
which is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 32 times
four which is 128 cars after seven
months will have gone to japan
and to vietnam
v of seven is going to be equal to two
times seven squared so that's equal to
two times 49 which is equal to 98 cars
so after seven months japan would have
received more cars so
japan
japan will have received more cars after
after seven months so this is
interesting we see that the exponential
function notice where you have the t as
the exponent that although it might
start off a little bit slower than this
what's essentially a quadratic function
when you have something squared it
starts off slower after five months you
would have shipped fewer cars than using
the quadratic model right over here but
then it more than catches up and it
starts to increase it at a faster and
faster rate and even by seven months
it's able to pass up the quadratic
function
which country will receive will have
received more cars from the cozy car
company
will the country which received more
cars from the cozy car company after
seven months continue to receive more
cars than the other country in future
months yeah absolutely once the
exponential function passes up the
quadratic function it just goes faster
it just keeps increasing at a faster and
faster rate and you could see that if we
wanted to do if we wanted to compare 8
months so j of 8 this is the exponential
function this would be 2 to the 8th
power which would be this times two
they'd get 256 cars and
v of eight
v of eight is going to be two times
eight squared which is two times 64
which is 128.
so notice now now we we would have
shipped twice as much to japan as
vietnam which isn't what the case right
over here we ship more to japan than
vietnam but not twice as much and we
could keep going we could if you want
you could go to j of you could go to j
of 9 j of 9 is 2 to the ninth power
which is going to be 256 times 2 or 512
cars while v of 9
v of 9 is going to be 2 times 9 squared
which is 2 times 81 which is
162. so now it's more way more than
double actually more than triple so you
see that once you get past that those
initial few months the the exponential
function is increasing at a much much
much faster rate and we can actually
visualize it let's actually get a
graphing calculator to visualize these
two things to see how that is happening
so let's graph it
so the first one let me graph the
exponential so 2
to the
2 to the well i'll just say x power
we'll say x is our independent variable
here so 2 to the x power
and then let's do the quadratic one this
is y 2 l w v of 2 let's say 2
times
x
2 x
x squared now let me set the range so
let me set the range here so let's see
let's say x starts at 0 and then let's
say it goes up to
let's say it goes up to 10.
let's say it goes up to 10. the x scale
could be 1 or yeah x scale could be 1.
now y's minimum let's say liz will start
at zero and then y max let's say let's
go to a thousand
let's go to a thousand and let's make
the y scale a hundred
one hundred and now i think we're ready
to graph so let's graph this let's see
what happens
so it's munching on things so that right
over there that's the exponential
and then there you see right over there
you have the quadratic and actually let
me zoom in a little bit on this so that
we can see where they pass where oh
actually let me
let me actually let me zoom in a little
bit on this so i'll do with the box so
that we can really see
we can we can see where they or attempt
to see where they pass each other up
so
i'm gonna
start there
i'm gonna make my box
let's see go
whoops
it's weird using a calculator on a
computer like this
but you see you definitely see even what
we've already graphed that the
exponential really just starts to shoot
up while the quadratic is just going
well it's still increasing at a decent
pace but nowhere near as fast and the
difference is becoming more and more
pronounced as time increases so let me
just make sure that's as low as that and
let's let's graph over in this range
right over here so let's see that right
over there that's the exponential
function that's 2 to the t power
and then that right over there is the
quadratic so you see you definitely see
actually let me you definitely see that
earlier on the quadratic has higher
values and you see that right over here
after five months we ship more cars with
to vietnam but then the exponential
passes it up and then just keeps
shooting faster at an ever increasing
pace